meanwhile the democrats who never let a
crisis go to waste are using the storm
to push their multi-trillion dollar
infrastructure bill
woe is us
if we don't recognize these changes are
due to climate change woe is us
if we don't do something about it
quickly we have to continue investments
in infrastructure working in partnership
with our federal government the federal
money to really that's the game changer
in terms of building the resilient
infrastructure we need what we're seeing
is we're going to need more than we ever
possibly imagined talking not billions
tens of billions even hundreds of
billions
to really be able to make people safe
well here now to react steve hilton host
of the next revolution uh on sundays 9
p.m we know that this is serious and we
want people to be helped but what we
also know is that this spending of money
it's like water now it's like monopoly
money spending it three trillion dollars
we're going to need hundreds of billions
and we also know that money gets lost
and misspent and there's fraud to the
tunes of tens and hundreds of billions
it's like a never-ending spigot how do
we approach this kind of serious problem
with these kinds of grifters who are
pushing the issue
but tommy i don't think you're taking
the problem seriously enough that you're
not taking the climate crisis seriously
i mean hundreds of billions is obviously
we need hundreds of trillions yes we're
going to take it seriously you're right
why stop at billions we need gazillions
and by the way i i want to get in on the
act two i want an award for bravery i'm
in my basement here in california
there's no flooding coming there's no
water there's a little bit of smoke in
the air from the wildfires i battled my
way through to talk to you tonight so
you know i want an award too look the
problem with these democrats now is that
the issue of um environmental protection
and conservation which actually a lot of
people can get behind a lot of
conservatives absolutely love nature we
unders we actually know a lot more about
nature than a lot of these people in
brooklyn or wherever who gonna
constantly lecture us about the
environment everyone could get behind
sensible policy discussions on that but
it's gone way beyond that for these
people it is now a religious mania any
single issue that crops up is just yet
another reason for them to push that
agenda so let's just take this issue of
hurricanes if you actually look at the
data the science they're constantly
telling us to look at the data death and
destruction from extreme weather events
is going down not up even specifically
on hurricanes the latest modeling of
north atlantic hurricanes shows that
there will be a five percent increase in
intensity a small increase in intensity
but a 25
decrease
in frequency they're going to get less
frequent that's what the modeling shows
so what are they talking about it's got
nothing to do with the actual issue it's
to do with what they really want which
is government control of the economy and
they'll use any excuse to get it well
and the climate change and that argument
is vague enough to where it can be
whatever they need it to be at any point
and everything can be explained as that
and it's frightening because this is a
dynamic which is a crisis and so people
begin to you know make different kinds
of decisions because logic and reason
enters it less into it and that's where
they take advantage of that i mean this
is so clearly what the use of fear
to to push government control to them
when as we've seen in the last seven
months that's the those are the last
people you want to have control your
lives speaking of which when it comes to
fear gavin newsom we know he's coming up
for the the recall election uh and he
has now stated bluntly that if he's
recalled people are gonna die
and uh you know it's covid it's all
these other decisions uh i think that
that's pretty uh desperate uh how does
thing how do things look like uh out
there for him and for the recall at this
point
well i mean by the way remember the last
time the democrats pushed this idea that
when they used death threats it was
actually during the pandemic and they
said if you gather with other people
unmasked then you're putting lives at
risk well guess who did that gavin
newsom so i think the french laundry so
i think we know how to seriously to take
this latest death threat that they're
issuing look the truth is he can't
believe he's in this position there was
a very revealing interview just the
other day with the atlantic where he was
basically whining about why he's in this
position and he said i used to be the
lucky one and then it all flipped on me
as if someone else is responsible for
this as if it's not him who actually cut
the wildfire prevention budget and then
lied about it as if it's not him who
failed to build any of the millions of
new homes that he promised and did
nothing about homelessness if it's not
him that shut down the schools while his
own kids went to private school as if
it's not him that's presided over this
record poverty and inequality and crime
and urban all the things that are
driving people to support the recall
particularly latinos that's the final
point i want to make they keep saying
this is a racist republican recall the
only racial group overall in california
in favor of recalling gavin newsom are
latinos that's because they've been
hardest hit by his stupid policies you
know i'll tell you it's like the golden
boy it like underestimated the normals
and that's exactly what happened here
not knowing that we have the details we
care we're not drooling we get this we
we've got two brain cells we can rub
together but he's the golden boy i i'm
supposed to have what i what i'm
supposed to have and get what i want
exactly yeah no
this is an incredibly important time
opportunity to make a statement steve
hilton thank you very much sir hey sean
hannity here hey click here to subscribe
to fox news youtube page and catch our
hottest interviews and most compelling
analysis you will not get it anywhere
else